now when i wanted to add touchscreen
support to the synthesizer application i
initially started with touch events
there were two challenges though first
you'll notice that on the desktop if i
don't have that touch event emulation
turned on it doesn't actually work at
all when i use the mouse
of course this is expected but i didn't
really want two code paths one for mouse
and one for touch secondly i really
wanted to be able to have a drag across
the keyboard play each note as you slid
across it in turn
but with the way touch delivers all the
events to the originally touched dom
element i would have had to calculate
the hit testing myself for these and
that was kind of a pain i really wanted
these touch events to be delivered to
the dom element for each key
instead what happens in this synth is
when i hit one key and then down
it doesn't actually move where the
events are delivered